private-sector investment or foreign
direct investment as it's usually
referred to is absolutely essential to
the poorest countries on the planet
because that is really what can lift an
economy that can in one swoop employ
tens of thousands of people particularly
if a major company comes in but laying
the foundation for major foreign direct
investment can take decades and Costa
Rica is a great example of this in Costa
Rica back
midway through the 20th century after
getting rid of their military decided
we're gonna invest in education we're
gonna invest in health and hopefully
someday major corporations will see us
as a place that's worth investing in and
sure enough starting in the 1980s
Microsoft Intel other companies started
setting up shop in Costa Rica so that's
the dream and that's certainly the dream
for a lot of poor countries and in a
country like Rwanda where I reside so
how do you actually get there and what's
it going to take to do that well there
are a number of things that governments
can do they can provide tax incentives
they can certainly lower levels of
corruption because companies
particularly multinational countries
want to dodge corruption they do not
want to have to pay bribes in order to
do business in a country and that sort
of is just the baseline beyond that a
country needs to build up its workforce
and convince these companies we have got
a workforce that's well-educated enough
that is oftentimes cheap enough for you
to come in and gain some sort of
competitive advantage over working in
another country Ireland is another
example of a country that did this they
invested immensely in education and
improve their tax laws and made it a
very attractive place to make
investments and they got it done but it
took many decades to do this the problem
in Africa right now is so many countries
don't just lack the workforce and don't
just have the high levels of corruption
and high cost of electricity and lack
basic infrastructure but they also have
public health challenges they have
malaria they have AIDS epidemics they
have lack of primary health care and
this together makes a perfect storm
for unattractive investment I mean who
wants to invest in a country where
you've got all of those problems against
you you want to invest in a country
where some of those problems are
starting to be resolved and Rwanda
happens to be a place that at least on
the public health from has done a great
job on the corruption front they've done
a great job on working on taxes they
still have a lot of challenges before
them but in general they're trying to do
everything that they can in order to
attract foreign direct investment